Think of a powerful memory.
Make it the happiest you can remember.
It feels like no time has passed and loads of time has passed.
I think this is the perfect time to sit down with everyone and reminisce.
The thing that scared me the most...
...was the implication that the most meaningful thing in our life is done...
...and there's something so joyous about seeing everyone,...
...and be like "It wasn't though."
One of the highlights of my part was when I had to pretend to be Hermione...
...pretending to be Bellatrix.
I don't like to be kept waiting.
I still got the teeth actually.
I'll put them in if you want.
My sister has children who were then around 10, 11, 12...
...and I said, "Martha, I don't know about this Voldemort."
"What?! You're being asked to play Voldemort?!"
"You've got to do it!"
I wouldn't be the person I am without so many people here.
It's a very heartwarming thing 'cause I've watched you grow up,...
...and I've seen kind of every stage of your life.
When things get really dark and times are really hard,...
...there's something about Harry Potter that makes life richer.
It's a strong bond that we'll always have.
We're family...
...and we will always be part of each other's life.